but look at this you have a new line of
drink mixers you have a
a partner with prosecco trailer called
bubble tap trailer you have a food home
line with qvc
let me ask you this this makes me think
one of two things
one you just love being busy you're an
entrepreneur
you love to just create you love to have
income coming in
have the fun of doing all these things
or you lost all your money in nsync
you have nothing left and you're
starting an empire all over again
no it's definitely the first one um you
know it's
uh you know a lot of my projects don't
make money so it's not
it's definitely not about the income
coming in um all my businesses that
we're launching this year
it really hurt um you know 2020 was
going to be a huge year for
lbp last fast productions um we were
launching virgin fest
uh with sir richard branson in june
which is going to be
an incredible music festival when we are
able to do it but it's postponed
um the mixer line i was coming out with
is now completely changed
we had to rebrand the whole entire thing
and that'll be coming out hopefully by
the end of the year
um so and in the bubble tap trailer of
course because of covid
is not running right now so all of my
businesses are kind of dormant right now
um except the podcast
and the writing of this movie right now
and then there's another tv show that
i'm doing
that we're writing right now too so you
like keeping busy you don't you're not
one of those
if you have too much time on your hands
oh it's the worst what happens to you
i usually get sick yeah if i if i if i
get
down time like i start kind of shutting
down it's very strange
but i've been that way since i was you
know a kid i joined in sync when i was
16 and
i mean your schedule just like bam bam
so you get used to this
life of if you don't have something
going on every minute
you feel like you're being lazy um that
you're not working
so you know after in sync i just kind of
kept that schedule and always you know
my my brain doesn't stop creating things
so
the tv and film like it's just like
constantly just creating stuff so
it doesn't stop so i needed to put that
into you know a good outlet
i mean aren't you fatigued with all the
work that you do constantly doing things
i always look at this and i'm like
i i don't like honestly i don't i look
at some careers who
who have millions and millions of
dollars in mansions and jets
and i'm like not for a million years i
don't want that life i don't want to
work
this movie into another movie into a
show and to this and to that
i don't know how people do that now what
what do you you and you have to do that
yeah i mean and you know i'm trying to
get to a point where i don't have to be
that crazy you know i always said
at 40 i wanted to kind of semi-retire
from in front of the camera you know and
really focus on being behind the camera
and that's what i'm kind of parlaying
into right now is
you know i i don't want to have to
constantly be
like you know getting jobs on tv just to
keep you know relevant whatever
i just want to be behind the scenes
write and produce great things
help other people out and enjoy life
actually
you know enjoy vacations and having some
time off and
we're starting a family now so i just
want to focus on kids
um and you know and i've been working so
hard just to get to that level
um so that's why 2020 was really
depressing because
all these projects were finally going to
launch and then all i had to do was
manage them
um and unfortunately that's delayed now
but starting
starting a family you want to have kids
oh yeah oh yeah wow how old are you now
i'm 41. no you're young you're young
yeah i mean yeah i'm young um
but i always said to myself look you
know i wanted a kid by 40. like you know
it's like if i'm gonna have kids like
40s the age you know you don't want to
be too old with a grandparent and all
that type of stuff
uh so yeah i and michael wants kids
you're both on the same page
oh yeah we've i mean that was one of the
reasons i knew
i was going to marry him because we we
both wanted to have kids
you know uh early on in our relationship
so then
yeah just time kind of gets away and
then we started
you know this ivf process about three
years ago
um and it's just been not a great
experience i mean i know a lot of people
have a lot of failed ivf
experiences but ours is just it's we've
gone through
so many donors and now so many
surrogates it's just been such a process
and you know last year we were pregnant
for you know a few weeks and
unfortunately
lost uh both of them uh and so now we've
made our embryos again and now we're
waiting for a surrogate
uh we gotta find another surrogate in
order to get pregnant because we were
supposed to be pregnant last week
and then our surrogate unfortunately
found a medical
issue that she can't carry the kids so
uh we gotta start all over again
it's been stressful oh i'm sorry that
sucks but you know what you know it's
gonna happen
just know it's gonna happen and maybe
with all the that's going on
maybe it'll be a nice christmas surprise
or hanukkah who knows i mean i hope so
and no in worst case if it doesn't work
this time
i mean we want to adopt anyway so we'll
just immediately go into adoption
you